ces mois ont passé pourtant julien
lalande est encore bouleversé par sa
brève visite au collège militaire de
kingston sa présence là bas comme
conférencière devait servir à
sensibiliser les cadets au harcèlement
et vos agressions sexuelles j'ai jamais
vu ça
elle aura eu droit à l'auditoire le plus
hostile qu'est ce que j'ai vu ça madame
des cauchemars je peux pas m'imaginer
c'est quoi la réalité d'être une femme
de 19 ans qui julie lalonde et une
intervenante très respecté et reconnu
c'est pour ça qu'en octobre dernier les
dirigeants du collège militaire l'ont
invité à prendre la parole devant près
de mille étudiants
voici le genre de commentaires auxquels
elle a été confrontée jeta rapt est
écoutée c'était un peu une femme fait
qu'on vous a dit c'est ce qui m'a dit en
pleine face oui fake c'est quelque chose
au sujet du rôle des femmes dans au
collège julie lalonde parle de cette
expérience pour la première fois trois
semaines après le dévoilement d'un
rapport accablant dans lequel l'ex juge
de la cour suprême marie deschamps
exposait une culture militaire au style
aux femmes et recommandait des gestes
concrets
l'impact à tous les niveaux non
seulement dans le milieu de vie
quotidien mais aussi dans le soutien aux
victimes
même dans les collèges militaire confus
et le rapport le harcèlement sexuel est
considéré comme un passage obligé et les
agressions sexuelles constituent un
risque douze au présent après sa
conférence julie lalonde avait fait part
de sa profonde déception sur les médias
sociaux et en retour des élèves
officiers ont répliqué par une série d'
insulte
il aura fallu cinq mois pour que le
collège s'excuse dans une lettre et à
n'être que le comportement de certains
étudiants n'étaient pas professionnels
il assure que des mesures ont été prises
sans en préciser la nature
wallace et pour leur rapport de madame
deschamps c'est la réalité qui font la
barre n'est pour julie lalonde la
culture militaire et la lenteur du
système reste le principal obstacle à
franchir pour que les femmes se sentent
pleinement acceptée et en sécurité dans
les forces canadiennes ici marc godbout
radio canada ottawa